Oh Valentine's Day when lovers thoughts
turn to romance apps okay okay not those
apps let's start with single and iPad
only app that's a great antidote to any
laws in your date night it's a
cooperative puzzle game that you and
yours play together by touching the
dedicated spaces on the screen and it
leads to lots of skin grazing so trim
those nails before you play finger
twister with your boo if you want to be
extra cautious about avoiding your ex on
set you're romantically loaded de
download cloak the app connects to your
various social accounts and pulls and
location data your friends are posting
across the network so you know what
places to avoid so if your ex post a
dinner photo with their new special
someone you will know that you should
order your giant bag of takeout from
elsewhere on a more hopeful note last
minute date night planners should
install no wait the app automatically
pulls up all the restaurants without a
wait for a table so you can breathe in
and sit down right away
no awkward 20 minutes crowded into a
foyer with strangers if you're happily
part of a couple though download avocado
it's an app specifically for people in
relationships to privately and securely
message send pics and you can digitally
hug and share calendars avocado can
confirm that your date is free for
dinner around 7:00 and it'll remind you
never to forget anniversaries birthdays
for Valentine's